So replication, this is a concept that isn't particularly unique to Unreal.
Obviously every online engine, every online game would have some kind of concept
for data going from the server to the client,
but replication in Unreal is kind of worth talking about
because it's got a lot of unique components that are kind of like probably more Unreal only.
So what actually is replication?
The term might be interchangeable, might be called other things,
but replication is basically the process of data going from the server to the client.
It gives server authority over client-side variables.
And essentially what the server will do is frequently check for whether or not
the information that the client has matches what's on the server.
So networked actors have a kind of a net update frequency,
and this is used to determine how often an actor replicates,
so how often we make these checks,
and the server will keep a kind of shadow set of data.
So that's the server, as well as the server having the actual data for what the value actually is,
it will keep a kind of copy for what the last thing it sent to each client was.
And the server is going to compare that shadow data against its current set of values.
And if there's a kind of mismatch, so if it's to say,
oh, this data is clearly changed from what I last sent to the client,
then it knows that it's going to need to kind of like send some information down to the client
to bring them kind of back up to date with what the server's current idea of everything is.
Obviously, this check comes with an inherent kind of network cost.
So there are things we can definitely do to kind of reduce that cost
and maybe not be making that check quite as often.
The cheapest one to do is updating our net update frequency,
which is essentially a little bit like reducing your tick time almost.
We've talked about doing that before as a way to kind of optimize your tick.
You can basically just check for replication, less frequency,
and that's through our net update frequency on a per-actor basis.
I think we may get into this a little bit later,
but it's something we've talked about before as well,
is that actor is our kind of like main point for dealing with replication.
Whilst components can be replicated to, actor is our kind of central entry point.
So a lot of this stuff is stuff that a lot of these networked concepts that we talk about
would be stuff that we do handle on the actor itself.
Net update frequency is actually an example of that.
In fact, you can just quickly jump into the engine.
I'm in the level blueprint here, but level blueprint is actually an actor,
so this should be here.
Update frequency, yeah.
Net update frequency, you can see it's there.
This would be available in any actor.
So, yeah, that's one of the quickest ways to kind of update this.
The quickest ways to kind of like make your game more net performant
is looking at your net update frequency.
It's one of the lowest hanging fruits.
It just comes back to that kind of, and a lot of this kind of network logic
is really just about that.
It's that kind of same core tenet of really all code optimization
is that doing something less is better.
The less you can do something, the better.
One of the kind of important things to bear in mind
when we're talking about replication,
one of the things that's often forgotten is that people can enjoin,
depending on your game setup obviously,
it's often a problem you hit up against
that people can join your game mid-session.
And so it's worth considering how you are passing data around
such that you maintain some kind of...
All the information that is stateful
isn't purely replicated through like function calls,
isn't just, oh, this information has changed
and therefore I'll just let everyone who's currently connected know
that you maintain some kind of persistent state
for all of the bits of information you care about.
And therefore, when a new player possibly joins 10 minutes
into your game, they get all the bits of information
they actually need and they don't get some kind of smaller subset
where you've got a mismatch between players that were here
for this initial bit of information getting broadcast out
and then the players who join afterwards who kind of missed that.
So what can be replicated?
Essentially, Unreal provides a lot of data types
that can be replicated out of the box.
The vast majority of data types are replicated,
but some are completely not.
And others require a little bit of nuance
and kind of understanding about how they actually work.
So straight off the bat, our atomic types,
our kind of fundamental types, bools, ints, floats,
all of these are going to be replicated.
Unreal also supports struct replication,
as long as the information in those structs
are one of these types that are already replicated.
It's worth mentioning that when we're dealing with structs,
as a kind of efficiency thing,
if you are changing information in a struct,
you don't need to change the overall struct.
We'll get into this a little bit, and then I've got an example
that shows this right at the end of the presentation.
But you can change individual bits of information in a struct,
and Unreal will understand that it's only that bit of information
that has changed and therefore only send that unique bit of information
within the struct over to the client.
Or if you're communicating that data back to the server
somehow the same way.
So you don't have to make a change to the whole struct
to say, oh, this will get replicated.
If a struct is replicated and you only change one member
within that struct, it is only that member
that will get passed over to the other clients.
Enums, obviously, even though they are kind of specialized types,
they are, under the surface, they are really a UN8,
and so they will be sent over the network
just as an atomic type, really.
Arrays are also supported,
and they're kind of smart things done about arrays
where if you make an overall change to an array,
then it's your first time,
then the whole array will be copied over.
But if you make changes to elements within an array
or you add a single element,
it's only those individual changes
that will get replicated over to the clients.
So, again, that is kind of an efficiency
that is already being done for you,
so you don't need to be super clever with these things.
It's worth mentioning, though, that when you are doing,
we've not talked about RPCs yet,
but when you are doing RPCs
and you're passing RPCs with arrays
and you're passing an array in as a parameter of that RPC,
the whole array will be copied over,
and you can't avoid that.
So just kind of a kind of anti-optimization
that's worth bearing in mind.
As with a lot of Tmaps,
they're unfortunately a little bit underrepresented
in lots of different aspects,
and replication is one of those.
So if you kind of want Tmap functionality,
one of the easy things that you can do,
for anyone who's not familiar with the term map,
there might be other terms that you've used for this,
but this is essentially the idea that you have a container,
you know, a type that contains multiple entries,
but rather than being represented by an index,
like an array, it's represented by a key type.
So you give it some kind of type
that represents a unique value,
and then it maps to a value.
So it's otherwise called key value pairs.
And if you need that kind of map-like functionality,
but you want it to be replicated,
you can do it via an array,
and if you override your,
in C++ at least,
if you override your functionality
to have an equality operator check,
then you can easily kind of find within that array.
It's not, there are performance differences, obviously,
but you get a lot of that same functionality.
And you can also use index of by key or find by key,
even if you don't want to do a direct
struct to struct comparison or value to value comparison,
you can use key types.
So just be aware that there are kind of like
ways around that for usage purposes,
but obviously there is a kind of meaningful
performance differences between a map and an array.
So, you know, it's not a perfect,
replication is not the right word to use there,
but it's not a one-to-one relationship,
but you can get a lot of the way there.
To all intents and purposes,
pointers are supported for replication in a sense,
but the things that are,
the pointers that are replicated are only pointers
to objects that are themselves replicated.
So you kind of need to have a knowledge of,
you know, all the data in your game that is replicated
to be know whether or not the object
that you're talking about is going to be kind of valid
to be replicated itself.
Essentially, when objects are replicated,
they are kind of given a unique ID
and that unique ID is itself replicated from server to client.
So it is consistent between the two.
And therefore, when you're passing a pointer around,
actually what gets replicated over the server
is that unique ID, and therefore it's easy for your client
to then rebuild that same connection and be like,
oh, they've passed in this unique ID,
I know what object has that unique ID
and therefore I'll hook that up on my local side.
So that that's how it works
and therefore pointers do work, they can be replicated,
but only pointers to objects
that are themselves replicated.
So how do we even make something replicated?
We've talked about kind of what replication itself means,
but how do we actually do this?
So there is essentially just a variable inside actors.
Like I said, actors are our kind of key entry point
for all of our kind of replication logic.
And there's essentially just a bool that represents
whether or not an actor is replicated.
If you just go to your actor,
there is a replicates, I think it's called.
Yeah, replicates.
And this can be true or false by default.
You can also set it at runtime
through a function called set replicates.
There are gonna be certain consequences to that.
It's not necessarily advisable
that you update these things at runtime
because there's probably gonna be
a lot of kind of weird consequences of that.
So the vast majority of the time,
you should be doing it within the body of the,
if you are gonna be doing set replicates true,
if you are gonna be calling that function,
you should probably be doing that inside your constructor.
But there probably are kind of workarounds
where you could hypothetically hack into that
and replicate that replicatedness over the server,
but that would be a little bit weird.
The vast majority of the time,
an actor should, this should be true
if an actor ever replicates and false if not.
And that's basically our starting point
for whether or not this thing can,
none of the rest of this is relevant
if the actor is not itself relevant.
And also with a component,
we have a similar variable.
And similarly, we've got that function
should be used done within the constructor.
If a component replicates
is not on an actor that replicates,
then it's completely irrelevant.
Components can only be replicated
when they are on an actor that replicates.
And then once something is replicated,
then that just means that this thing
can make use of replication functionality,
but there are additional steps that we have to take
whenever we actually want to mark something as replicatable.
So first off, if it's data,
you know, typically when we're talking about replication
that we're talking about like actual variable replication.
And that is, we would do,
we would have to have types
that can be marked up with a U property.
So we know what this means from previous sessions
that, you know, you really,
you can only mark something up as a U property
if it's inside either a U struct or a U class
as we've spoken about.
So all of this is only applies
to anything that inherits
is part of the U object hierarchy chain.
And you would just add,
if you just want data that is replicated
from server to client,
you would just put the replicated markup above it.
And the other option is replicated using,
which basically gives us replication,
but with additional callbacks.
So with replicated using,
what you do is you, this is essentially saying
this data does get replicated from server to client,
but additionally to that,
there is a function that will be called
and here is what that function is called.
The name does matter.
I'll go into this in a little bit,
but it does need,
this onRep underscore is a kind of requirement,
but then what you call the function after that
is kind of completely up to you.
It doesn't have to have any correlation
with the actual data that you are replicating.
It's worth noting that data won't be replicated
if it's the same, if it's already,
if you make a change on the server
and it's not changed from what the client thinks,
then that information is not going to get replicated over.
So it's worth bearing that in mind
in the context of onRep,
if you're relying on your onRep function to get called,
but you haven't actually changed the data,
that's not going to change anything.
It's also worth mentioning that if you are relying
on your onRep functions getting called,
if you are in single-player,
and I believe also on your Listen server,
then your onRep functions won't necessarily get called.
So you kind of need to account for that.
On replication is only really for when data
is getting passed from the server to a client.
So when you're in standalone,
that relationship kind of isn't there
and therefore your onRep functions
won't be getting called.
So you need to account for that
and possibly develop alternative avenues
if your game is a game that can be played
both single-player and multiplayer,
and you're relying on this onRep functionality.
The other thing that you will need to do
is put any variables.
So replicated and replicated using
are not enough on their own.
You also have this function,
which is get lifetime replicated properties,
and you basically need to pass in some macros
to essentially say,
this is data that will get replicated.
And you're essentially going to be passing in
the same variables that you've put replication markup above.
You're going to pass in the name of the class
that this is within,
and then the name of the variable itself.
I've not actually spent a huge amount of time
looking into the macro itself,
but I suspect what this is doing,
there are other parts of the engine that do this,
is I suspect that this is doing a compile time checking
just to make sure that you've spelled this name correctly.
And therefore, if you're, you know,
this is called sumVar,
and then you just make a editor change
and you change that to sumVar2,
I suspect it's going to be a compile time check
so that the compiler will complain at you to say,
hey, you've not correctly renamed this.
There's no variable called sumVar anymore.
So, you know, you need to update that.
There are alternative options as well.
It's not just the do rep lifetime macro.
There is an additional one called do rep,
there are a couple of actually,
but the other kind of one that's worth bearing in mind
is the do rep lifetime condition,
which lets us specify some kind of additional parameters
where this should only replicate across the client
in certain situations.
We've actually got an example,
so we'll come to kind of,
the reason I've actually made this
is for demoing a couple of other,
I'm sorry, jumping to the wrong actor there,
demoing this for a couple of different reasons,
and we'll kind of get towards this
at the very end of the session,
but just to kind of show some of this in situ,
as you can see, we've got a float here.
This is inside a U class.
Obviously, again, we can't have U properties
if it's not inside either a U struct or a U class.
So we have an actor here.
I'll actually demo this actor,
like I said, at the end of the session,
but we've got a variable here.
I wanted to replicate this variable.
Therefore, I have to do a U property markup above it.
I have to say it's replicated,
and then that alone is not enough.
I have to make sure that that is inside an actor
that is replicated or a component that is replicated
on an actor that is replicated.
And so you can see,
if I jump to my constructor for my actor,
you can see I've done all the relevant things.
We'll talk about relevancy in a moment,
but you can see that in the constructor,
we've said this actor replicates.
And the other thing we've done is added,
saying I do rep lifetime.
We've passed in our actor class,
and we've passed in the variable name,
so sum replicated float.
All of that are the things that you need to do
to make sure that this variable
will actually get replicated.
And then here we have,
we're making use of this on rep, this rep using.
So you don't need to say replicated and rep using.
Rep using can be done.
It inherently implies that this value is replicated.
And then you pass in the function
that will actually get called
when this value gets replicated to.
So this, again, the name here doesn't have any bearing
on the actual data that's replicated.
You're just saying this function will get called
when this value gets replicated into.
But the on rep is important.
So this function is just down here.
It is important that this function is a U function.
If it isn't a U function, it won't get properly found.
This is all using the Unreal Reflection system.
So this function has to be a U function.
And similarly, you can see that,
when inside that function,
we don't need to go into great detail about this,
but we're just basically printing a string.
So when this value gets updated
and replicated onto the client,
that value, we're gonna do some printing.
And similarly, we have to do for replicated using values
as well as replicated values,
we have to add them to this
get lifetime replicated props.
You also wanna be sure that you call your super function
here because there's gonna be data further down the chain
that is also replicated.
So you don't want to forget to call that
so that the parent class functions are getting called.
And then here, we've got this example
of the do rep lifetime condition.
This condition, there's a whole suite of these
that you can kind of look at,
but so you can kind of jump into cornet types.h
and look at those.
But the example that I've given
is this particular type,
the sum replicated struct variable,
we've marked it to only get replicated
for simulated actors.
We'll talk about what that kind of meaning is,
but it essentially means that on the owning,
on the person, on the connection on the client
that actually owns this actor,
i.e. for the case of a pawn,
that the client that is actually controlling this pawn,
this data won't get replicated to them.
So this particular condition is one
that you might use if it's data
that you know will actually kind of come from the client.
So say, for example,
your client is making local changes
to their customization.
So they've changed what hat they're wearing
and they make that change locally on their client
and then replicate that data to the server.
Therefore, that might be data
that the server doesn't need to replicate back
to the client because they know the client
through other alternative means
will have the most up-to-date idea of that information.
And therefore, they only need to replicate it
to the clients that aren't owning this actor itself.
That's just an example of the kind of condition
you might want to place on your variables
when they get replicated.
Otherwise, this is basically saying,
replicate this data to all clients
whenever they pass other checks
that we'll get to in a little bit.
The other thing to bear in mind with any passing data
from the server to the client is it takes time.
Obviously, these things aren't instantaneous.
When testing, sometimes it can feel that way,
but depending on how far away your server is
from your client and depending on their internet speed,
you could be talking fractional seconds,
you could be talking multiple seconds.
So do bear that in mind.
Don't rely on things being instantaneous
because they are not.
So when we're talking about function calls,
we've talked about the idea of passing data
over replicated data, but we also have RPCs.
RPCs are a term that is not necessarily unique to Unreal.
This is something that exists in other engines.
I think it's a kind of general term,
but if you're not familiar with it,
RPC stands for remote procedural.
It's essentially a little bit like a function
that you send over the network.
So we can, there's a couple of different,
RPCs aren't one thing.
It's kind of a whole subset of things.
We can send, we can do a function call
from, we can go from a client to a server.
We can go from the server to a specific client,
as long as we are calling that function on an object
that's ultimately owned by a particular client.
Each player controller, as we kind of all the way back here,
we kind of said, we've got this relationship
where the server has every player controller
and then every client has their own player controller
and no one else's.
So that's, as I said,
this kind of one-to-one unique connection
that each client has with the server.
So that's where this kind of comes in here,
is that when we're doing kind of client function calls,
that is, those are to be done on objects
that they are only gonna get called
on that unique player controller.
So each player controller kind of represents
that unique connection between the client
and the controlling server.
So when a client is communicating information
back to the server,
they can only do it through their player controller
and obviously they can only do it
about objects that they are the owner for.
And then we have this kind of third type.
So we have, you know, client to server,
obviously that can only be done
on objects that the client owns.
Server to client, that's with the intention
that we're kind of communicating that information
to an individual client,
also through their player controller.
And then we have this kind of net multicast.
This is a little bit,
we talked about delegates, I believe in our second session,
we have the idea of multicast delegates.
So that's the kind of information
that is just broadcast everywhere.
It's the same kind of concept here.
And this is basically a function
where it's not from client to server,
it's only of a server to client.
And this is a kind of shotgun function
that broadcasts to every single client
and therefore require no player controller
because they're just gonna let every client know about this.
So the way that we would do this
is similar to how we had to do U property markup
with replication.
For RPCs, we have U function markup.
So this implies certain things, right?
For a function to be an RPC,
it has to be a U function.
And for U functions to exist,
they have to exist within a U struct or a U class.
So all of that logic all kind of bubbles down.
And yeah, we can specify one of those three configurations.
We can specify if it's a client, a server, or a net multicast.
The other thing that we can mark up
is whether or not a function is reliable or unreliable.
So yeah, in the context of this,
again, is not necessarily unique to Unreal,
but reliable functions are essentially functions
that you can trust will always make their way to the client.
They may not necessarily get there instantaneously.
They may take time.
If the client has some kind of package loss
or if their connection gets disrupted,
it might take quite a bit of time.
And unreliable functions are essentially functions
that, you know, due to packet loss,
due to connection problems, there may be a kind of like,
essentially this function might get lost.
So you need to kind of bear that in mind
when you're marking functions as reliable or unreliable.
Reliable functions aren't just magically, you know,
the temptation can just be to mark every function as reliable.
But actually, the general advice
is to make as many things unreliable as possible,
only the absolute most key functions to make reliable.
And that's because reliable kind of has extra cost.
When functions are marked as reliable,
they kind of enter a queue
and they kind of maintain both on the server
and, you know, it's almost like it maintains
that shadow set of data to make sure
that this data does actually make its way to the client.
So they are more expensive to both call and maintain.
So therefore, if a function can be unreliable,
it should be unreliable.
But you just have to kind of understand that,
you know, there is a world where that function
never makes its way to the kind of receiving client
if there are connection problems or anything like that.
The other thing that to kind of bear in mind
is that we've also got this capability for validation.
So validation is additional markup
that we can do on the RPC.
And essentially, it lets us specify
kind of an additional set of data.
So with validation, as when we specified on rep,
what that means is we can kind of add some additional function
that will return either true or false.
And this is basically a way of primarily
for things like cheat detection.
And if we return true, then it was validated.
If we return false, then essentially the server
will instantly kick this connection.
So typically, you know, you want to be returning true.
You don't want to be kicking everyone off your connection.
But it's there for if we imagine we have an RPC
that the client can tell the server
they've reloaded their clip
and this is the amount of ammo they reloaded.
You could do some kind of simple check
for whether or not the amount
that they're trying to reload by
is even a sane amount that could ever possibly be reloaded.
And if not, maybe you can only ever reload one bullet at a time
or you know what the maximum clip size is for their gun.
If they're trying to reload some kind of bogus amount,
then that's an example of how you could,
you know, use some kind of gameplay data to validate against
and therefore, you can assume that they're cheating,
if not, and then they'll get kicked off.
So that validation, unlike our RPC,
when we do with validation,
that we don't specify a unique function name,
we simply have our existing function name
and we will basically have additional markup.
So for anyone who's used to doing delegates,
it would look the same way.
You have the function that you actually say,
hey, this function is, you know, is an RPC
and it would look like this.
Here's its kind of signature, here's its name,
here's the parameters it takes in.
Then when you actually do the implementation for that
in your C++, it would look like this.
So you don't necessarily have to declare this in the header,
but in your body, it would look like this.
Your, the kind of actual header element of this
should kind of get automatically generated for you.
If for some reason you wanted that to be a virtual function,
you would probably need to declare that in your header
as a virtual version of the same function.
But otherwise, the kind of,
in the header that will already exist,
but it's only in the body,
you would need to do your function name,
underscore implementation.
And this is the thing that would actually get called
when the RPC kind of filters through to the client.
And then you would just do whatever you wanted
your game logic to do in here.
And then last of all, we have the validate
and the same thing,
it's whatever your function is called, underscore validate.
And then this would be,
have to be a bool function
that returns either true or false.
And again, if this returns true,
then it's pass validation.
If it returns false,
then that connection is gonna get kicked.
So be very careful when you're returning false.
Yeah, I think that's everything to kind of say
about our kind of core markup.
So as we said already,
we have kind of three ways of marking a function up.
We can mark it up as server, client or multicast.
When it's a server,
that means it's called from the client to the server.
So this is the client communicating data to the server.
This should only be called on objects.
This is essentially all through the,
these first two are all through the player controller.
So this should only be called on objects
that are owned by a particular player controller.
So, you know, an example would be your,
the pawn that player is currently controlling.
They are owned by that player controller
and therefore they are owned by that connection.
So that's the client communication information to the server
that might, an example might be passing input along.
I just gave an example that a player might
on their local machine, do their customizations
as in when they've kind of locked those customizations in
that that might then be a server call
to kind of communicate that information to the server
to say, hey, server, I've updated all my customizations
and now let the other clients know
that my hat should look different or something like that.
Then we have client functions.
This is functions called on the,
from the server to individual clients.
Again, this is through a player controller.
So this is about a particular owned connection.
And then we have multicast that we already talked about.
This is a kind of shotgun.
This is our function that is just called everywhere.
So this might be any data that is kind of like everyone.
I know for a fact that every connected client
will need to know about this.
That might be a case for a multicast.